Thank you for a second. Well, there was
the year before they launched cern, uh,
that little article and open up a,
that black hole that it will create a
particle that would devour the fabric of
the universe. Yeah. It was a black hole.
It would expand and expand
and expand until what we did.
God, man, maybe we restarted. Yeah. Yeah.
Maybe we were in a parallel universe.
Maybe we were knocked off our timeline
into another place. It makes less sense.
Yeah, it was, it was the
things going on in the unit,
a little radios that the evidence of
multiple universes that we pop in and out
of different realities. Right? Like
the fact that we, it's a multiverse,
the Ford logo,
let's say.
Do you remember you recognize this
part of the Ford logo and they see,
most people never noticed it. This weird
little squiggle in the AF. Really? Yeah.
And they said the Fedex thing blows
people's minds to what's that?
It's the Arrow. What Arrow? Exactly.
Bring ups. Fedex. If you
never, if you, you'll never
not see the Arrow again. Yeah.
Same thing with the Ford logo.
It's like there's perceptions.
It's like hmm. And sit there the
whole time and I didn't. Yes,
I didn't know there was an arrow there.
There people will insist that
the Fedex Arrow is really, oh,
interesting. Okay. But that's an
accidental arrow. No, you'd think so.
They designed it in there.
Where's the air?
They definitely designed it right there.
Yeah, right there. The white part? Yeah.
Oh now. Oh yeah. Now I never see it
again or never not see it again. I know.
It's funny,
Huh?
But I mean that could be like four years
before it was the little squiggle in
the f Jews. Why is that a squiggle?
Why is it that that's ridiculous?
Cause it actually makes an effort like
that. Yeah. It actually spells fjord.
Yeah. Or food. If your
[inaudible] is that an eye?
What is it? Why did they squeak a
lot? Did they do that? Oh, it's not.
That didn't use to do that in
Richmond to say it's time. It's time.
It's right in front of you that you don't
think that's right. Yeah, that's right.
You the people who insist that
Miguel had died in jail, in jail.
So was there always a squiggle? When did,
what is that? Is that a real forward,
that little thing? When did
they make the squiggle? Okay.
That's normal because that's
what I thought. The fourth
thing look like someone,
until I saw this maybe in a village
that they stopped the squiggle.
At some point they must have, or the
opposite. Maybe they add the squiggle,
bring up the swiggle without some monitor.
Do the research. What's a modern Ford?
Go to a,
you put 2019 Ford Mustang.
Let's see that. Let's see if they'd
have the squiggles. A squiggle.
Now it does some,
the squiggle asshole wanted to justify
his existence by ruining their beautiful
logo. Yeah. Um, let's see. I mean,
logos do change that does the squiggle
squiggle? Yeah. That's a new Mustang.
So the squiggle was occurrent.
Yeah. Yup. The squiggles current.
It really doesn't fit.
No, it looks stupid.
It would look better without
that stupid score home.
The only thing that's saving
that squiggles that no one
noticed it up until now.
Oh Great. Now, I'm never going to notice
the Mandela effect. I Hate Mandela effect,
but that just seems like people fucking
with something that's not broken. Yeah.
Right. Yeah. Um, it's like,
let's just make it up. Right.
Remember when they came up with a
new coke? Fuck God was like a riot.
A riot on their heads of a parallel
universe. It's just a stupid idea.
Just ruined coke. Yep. Jeff, the cokes
made with real cocaine. The original coke.
Yeah. No, today. Today. Yes.
What that the at that they
replaced it with caffeine. No,
they use coca leaves. Smack in the
coca leaves for flavor. Yes. In fact,
the company, dude, it's crazy. The
company that makes the cocaine,
the um,
the company that uses the coca leaves
that brings in the coca leaves to make
Coca Cola is the number one.
You creator of medical grade cocaine,
they use that coca leaf to also
make medical grade cocaine.
There's no cocaine in,
in Coca Cola,
but there is a flavor that's a
bunch of different four logos. Yeah.
Over the years I drink diet
coke. Would you? Seven,
1927 to 2003. All of them. Huh. Huh?
I like the one in 1903, that's
actually a pretty dope. Um,
Google coke.
They use coca leaves to make Coca
Cola. They still do. They actually do.
And then the company does that
cause it makes cocaine because the,
yeah cause the recipe for its coats,
laser herbal.
There's like a lot of herbs that go
into coke. Yes. It's a flavor. Yeah.
But the Diet coke is just chemicals.
It's all artificial.
Remember I was in school in the new
coke thing happened and then Celia,
this advertising besides producing
the cocoa flavor agent for Coca Cola,
the Stephan company extracts
cocaine from the coca leaves,
which sells it to Mallon.
Crocked a Saint Louis Missouri
pharmaceutical manufacturer.
That is the only company the United
States licensed to purify cocaine from
medical use. But digital
use. Yeah, there you go.
So they actually using actual coca
leaves. So someone, I guarantee you,
if you follow the paperwork,
there's a bunch of cocaine hanging
around residual to those guys.
They get a little bit here and there at
work gives you a little pep me up. Right.
That's what's amazing is that you're
not allowed to chew the leaves.
Cause apparently chewing the leaves is
really healthy. Yeah. You get flavonoids.
It's actually good for you and it gives
you a pickup that's very similar to
caffeine.